Looking at that picture on the screen.
The lead prosecutor in this case is.
That's Chris Conroy who
who's been at the DA's
He's a long term
assistant district attorney
and he's been there for for a long time.
The woman behind him is Susan Hopfinger.
She's the attorney who who prosecuted
successfully prosecuted
the Trump Organization
and got a 17 count conviction where her
the opposing counsel was Susan necklace
the woman seated to Mr.
Trump's right. And.
And then you have obviously
the same judge, Judge Mershon there
and with that,
just to be clear
that Susan Hopfinger is the woman the
the gentleman at the prosecutor's
table was Chris Conroy.
You sit your seat
behind him with the black jacket
in the white shirt.
Okay.
That is an inference
that Susan Hopfinger sitting right
sitting behind, says
she she's the head of the whole
investigation division,
which is the White Collar
arm of the Manhattan DA's office.
So she she
she was a defense attorney before
and she was a prosecutor before that.
And Mr. Bragg, D.A.
Bragg brought her back to lead
his investigation division,
which is a it's an executive level
position, very prestigious.
And like I said,
she was the trial lawyer
who successfully tried
the case against the Trump Organization
and got the 17 count
conviction on behalf of the office.
And Karen, who is the
who is the woman
at the table with Chris
Conroy to our left
his right in the blue dress.
She's another A.D.A.
on the case
who works in the major
economic crime bureau.
This is
the team
is going to have multiple attorneys
on on it.
And the question is we just didn't know
who was going to be the lead lawyer
who's going to be speaking on the record.
It could have been Susan Hopfinger,
it could have been Peter Pope
or others
who are at an executive level
who are working on this case.
Chris Conroy is a senior
investigative counsel.
He's he's just an ADA.
I should say he's he's
an assistant district attorney,
a very senior, seasoned, excellent lawyer
who they are
having be the ADA who the ADA
meaning assistant district attorney
who will be arraigning Mr.
Trump and speaking on the record.
So and
the interesting context
you also brought up
is that
Susan Hopfinger, the woman
with the white shirt and black jacket,
sitting behind
Chris Conroy
at the prosecutor's table,
just defeated in court the woman
Susan necklace in the green suit
at the defendant's table right
next to Donald Trump
in the Trump Organization.
Case,
which was a big victory
for District Attorney
Alvin Bragg, I believe. Right.
Exactly. Exactly right.
17 felony count conviction
against the Trump organization.
And Cory Booker,
worth noting that
that case ended in fines.
I mean, it was it was convictions.
And the case was successfully prosecuted
from a prosecutor's perspective.
But the end result was fines
for the Trump Organization.
I just think we have to keep that
in context.
Right.
Terms of this,
you know,
even though this particular proceeding
today has a lot of gravity to it
and the former president is sitting there
at the defendant's table.
There are a lot of possible outcomes
and some of them are
other than the former president ending up
with a felony conviction.
Some of them could potentially
be something as simple as that.
Absolutely.
And all of us should in the in journalism
and in the public, should be
skeptical and open minded
when it comes to any accusations
made by the government
against any individual.
And we'll see exactly
what the district attorney, Alvin
Bragg is is proceeding
with against Donald Trump when he brings
this indictment forward,
which we're told has been unsealed,
although the public is still waiting
to see it.
Adam Kaufman, let me just ask you,
when we're told Trump pleads
not guilty to 34 counts,
which is what
a New York government official
has told CNN.
34 counts.
What does that mean?
Is that 34 different felonies?
Is it 34 misdemeanors?
Is it
one felony and 34
counts of that one felony?
Translate that
into into public speaking for us.
Right.
So so we we don't know
we don't know what the counts are.
We know
because this is a felony indictment
being arraigned in Supreme Court
that at least one count is a felony.
If it's the falsifying business records
under New York state procedural law,
every time
there is a false business record,
it would have to be
charged as a separate count.
And so it is entirely possible
that it's all multiple counts
because every fake check or every fake
entry and a
in a ledger
would be its own discrete count.
That's another possibility
to go back to the way the arraignment
probably worked.
You would expect the court
to simply generally
the court will simply inform
the advise the defendant
that a New York County
grand
jury has filed an indictment
charging you with
and then they'll list the counts
and then ask the defendant,
how do you plead guilty or not guilty?
And that's the point when when Mr.
Trump would have entered his plea
of not guilty.
But at this point,
we just don't know what
all of those different counts are
and what the indictment contains.
And how long does it take
for an indictment
to go
from being unsealed to posted online?
Especially when you have
when you have something
that is
of such public interest internationally.
It's surprising to me
I mean,
you know, in
some of the more high profile cases that
were handled when I was there
and I know
Karen
Karen can also share this experience
you have it
sort of teed up and ready to go.
You know,
you have to wait for the unsealing
at the arraignment,
but you also have
someone sort of standing
by to feed that indictment out
because the media is waiting for it.
So I'm
a little surprised
that we're not seeing it yet.
Interesting.
Andy McCabe, any any thoughts
and reactions to this?
The images
we're getting from
inside
this courtroom are just extraordinary.
The annoyed, chastened Donald Trump
The reports that he has pleaded
not guilty to 34 charges.
We're still waiting,
of course,
to hear what they are
still waiting to hear what they are.
And and I would say
still waiting to understand
what exactly is still taking place
in that courtroom, he says.
As others have mentioned,
this is really going on at least twice
as long as any of us expected.
My guess,
and this is speculation is the
you know, the battling over issues
and motions
and scheduling
has probably already begun.
One of the goals
that the judge will have had
in this first arraignment
would be to set up
at least
a provisional schedule
of when those motions would be due
So you can imagine, we've already heard
reporting from the Trump
legal team that they intend to fight.
I think they said
every issue related to this
related to this case.
And my guess is that
those battles have probably already
begun behind the closed doors.
And 100 Center Street.
Carrie Cordero, let me ask you, the Trump
defense team has already signaled
that they are immediately
going to make a motion
to have this case
dismissed, that
they think it's nonsense, that they don't
think these charges hold water,
that it's misdemeanors, etc.
Would they make that motion
at this court appearance
or would it be for a later appearance?
Normally,
I think they would take more time
to be able
to actually write out their motions.
I mean,
they could have started drafting it
based on what they think was coming,
but they got to really be able
to look at the documents.
So I don't think they would make a motion
to dismiss orally in front of the judge
because they want to
make every single possible
written argument
that they can in their brief.
But I would expect that they would do it
relatively soon.
I don't
I don't think it would be during
this proceeding, but soon.